[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رئيس بيلاروسيا قوات فاجرت السر على
التوجه نحو بولندا واجد صعوبه في ايقافهم
تبحث مع الناس عن استراتيجيه جديده لتصدير
الحبوب فهل تسمح موسكو بذلك وحيله روسيه
لاخفاء الاسلحه تضع الاقمار الصناعيه في
موقف محرج والغرب يضع اوكرانيا كفارسه
سهله خلال الهجوم المضاد ولوكاشينكو يضع
خريطه الجحيم امام بوتان الرئيس الروسي
لورسو لن ندعكم تاخذوا حتى شبرا واحدا من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وبرغم الضغوطات واشنطن
ترفض الطلبه الاوكراني الاكثر الحاحا
والجيش الاسرائيلي في مهب الريح خلال 48
ساعه وتايوان تستعرض قواتها امام التنين
الصيني
مقاتل فاغنار يتحرشون بولندا
اختيار العدو جزء مهم لضمان نتائج الحرب
ومن اختار الدب عدوا له فقد بات خطته
بالفشل وخسر الحرب قبل ان تبدا وها هي
بولندا تختار الدب الروسي ليكون خصمها في
الحرب القادمه الم ياخذ البولنديون الدرس
من الجاره اوكرانيا لا لا اعتقد ذلك وهنا
يجتمع الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر
لوكاشينكو بنظيره الروسي وحليفه القوي
فلاديمير بوتين ليطلع لوكاشينكو بوتين على
خريطه لنقل قوات بولنديه الى حدود دوله
اتحاد روسيا مشيرا الى ان وارسو تلقي
بقواتها الى الجحيم واكد لوكاشينكو ان احد
الالويه الفولاذيه يتمركز الان على بعد 40
كيلومترا من مدينه بريست غربيه بيلاروس في
حين ان لواء اخر ينتشر على مسافه حوالي
100 كم من مدينه قرودنو
التي تريده هذه القوات البولنديه هناك
ليعجب لوكاشينكو بان هناك مخططا لتقسيم
اوكرانيا وانضم اجزاء منها لبولندا مؤكدا
ان
غرب اوكرانيا في تحركاتهم الرافضه لضمهم
الى بولندا لينضم اليه بوتين قائلا ان فصل
غرب اوكرانيا وتقطيع اوصال البلاد امر غير
مقبول بالنسبه لروسيا ليعود لوكاشينكو
ويفجر المفاجاه بتحذيره ان قوه فاكنار
التي تتمركز حاليا في بلاده طلبت منه توجه
نحو الاراضي البولنديه واضاف انه بالكاد
يوقفها وهنا رساله واضحه لبولندا ان لم
تتراجع فسنطلق العنان التي تنتظر الحرب ضد
وارسو على احر من الجمر فهل وصلت الرساله
وفي سياق الحرب لكن في اوكرانيا عاد بوتين
ليؤكد ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد قد باء
بالفشل وهناك اضاف بوتين ان قوته دمرت عدد
القياسيا من المعدات العسكريه الاجنبيه
خلال عمليه خاصه في الاربع والعشرين ساعه
الماضيه مشيرا الى ان خسائر قوتك بلغت 26
الف قتيل منذ بدايه
الى تدمير القوات الروسيه اكثر من 15
دبابه المانيه واكثر من عشرين عربه برادلي
امريكيه في معركه واحده فيا لها من ارقام
مرعبه لكننا لا نتحدث دون مصدر وها هو
موجود امامكم من جانبها تحدثت صحف امريكيه
بان الغرب كان يعلم ان اوكرانيا لا تمتلك
اسلحه
كججمها المضاد بنجاح مضيفه ان الغرب كان
يامل في ان تعوض شجاعه ومهاره الاوكرانيين
النقص في الاسلحه فعن اي شجاعه يتحدثون
ويال خيالهم الواسع انها ليست افلام
هوليودي هؤلاء وفي اوديسا قال المتحدث
باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب في الجيش
الاوكراني لاديسلاف نازاراف ان شخصين قتل
واصيب اكثر من 20 في قصف روسي استهدف
المدينه خلال الساعات الماضيه مضيفا ان
القوات الروسيه استخدمت ما لا يقل عن خمسه
انواع من الصواريخ من بينها الصواريخ
اونيكس واسكندر بينما قالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان قوتها شنه الليله الماضيه غاره
على منشات يتم فيها التحضير لاعمال
ارهابيه باوديس حسب تصريحهم من جهته اكد
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني ان الهجوم على
اوديس هو الاكبر على ميناء حيوي للامن
الغذائي العالمي ليخرج الرئيس الاوكراني
متواعدا بان الضربه الروسيه على اوديسا لن
تمر بدون رد
ومعك واشنط
ن وكذلك نداءات حكومه كيا في المرحه
لامداد اوكرانيا بالصواريخ بعيده المدى
لكن الولايات المتحده لا تزال متمسكه
بالرفض في الوقت الحالي على الاقل بحسب
مسؤولين امريكيين ودعونا نعود قليلا نحو
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الذي لا ندري هل
اندلع حقا ام لا وبرغم تاكيد جميع
التقارير الغربيه ان الهجوم كان مخيبا
للامال ولم يحقق النتائج المنتظره ذهب
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
بتصريح مفاجئ متحدثا عن مكاسب كبيره
وبتصريحات لشبكه سي ان ان اوكرانيا
استعادت 50% من اراضيها التي احتلتها
برايكم من اين يستقيم لينكن اخباره واما
نحن ومن اين اتينا بهذا الخبر فاليكم
المصدر يقول بلينكين بان كييف نجحت والجيش
الاوكراني في استعاده 50% من الاراضي التي
سيطرت عليها روسيا منذ بدايه هذه العمليه
العسكريه
ذكر المعارك في اوكرانيا فقد تحدثت مجله
نيوز واكل الامريكيه في تقرير لها عن حيله
روسيه نشات لها موسكو لخداع اوكرانيا حيث
رسم الروس طائرات مقاتله في مطار بالقرب
من شبه جزيره القرمله تسيطر عليها روسيا
وذلك للتشويش على الطائره المسيره
والاقمار الصناعيه الاوكرانيه لتوجه
ضرباتها نحو الرسومات فيا لها من حيره
ماكره ومن حرب الباروت الى حرب البطون
الخاويه حيث بحث الرئيس الاوكراني فلادي
مع الامين العام للناتو فتح ممر لتصدير
الحبوب في البحر الاسود بعد ايام قليله من
انتهاء العمل باتفاقيه مع روسيا بهذا
الصدد فهل يتجاهل الناتو تهديده موسكو بان
اي سفينه تحمل الحبوب في البحر الاسود هي
هدف مشروع وفي سياق اخر هنا ضربه روسيه من
نوع اخر للغرب حيث حقق سعر بيع النفط
الروسي ارتفاع تجاوز لاول مره منذ بدء
القيود الغربيه حاج 60 دولارا للبرميل
ويشير ذلك حسب صحيفه
الى نجاعه الجهود الروسيه التي بذلتها
لبيع نفطها في الاسواق الدوليه وبعيدا عن
فشل العقوبات الغربيه نقل موقع بيزنس ان
عده دول اوروبيه تسعى للحصول على انظمه
صواريخه مارس الامريكيه بعد نجاحها في
الحرب في اوكرانيا
الاحداث والتطورات حذر رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي هرتسيها ليفي قاده اسرائيل انه
في حاله تمرير التعديلات القضائيه فسيكون
هناك ضرر حقيقي على الجيش وسينهار في غدون
48 ساعه وهناك اعلنها لي في تعليق عشره
الاف من جنود الاحتياط من جميع وحدات
الجيش الاسرائيلي الخدمه احتجاجا على
التعديلات القضائيه استعدادات في تايوان
لاجراء مناورات عسكريه تستعرض قدرتها على
التصدي لاي غزو محتمل بينما كانت الصين قد
استبقت تلك المناوره بارس ال عشرات
الطائرات الحربيه والسفن العسكريه قباله
الجزيره وتشمل المناوره التايوانيه اضافه
للتدريبات العسكريه تدريبات تهدف الى
اعداد المدنيين على التعامل مع الكوارث
الطبيعيه والقيام بعمليات الاجلاء في حاله
وقوع غارات جويه
[موسيقى]